si je vous demandais de faire des petits
groupes de quatre personnes
parce que je vais faire un tirage je
fais retirer 1 1 million de dollars dans
chacun des petits groupes
pensez vous vos chances de gagner de
retourner à la maison millionnaires sont
pas mal bonne ouais si vous vivez
jusqu'à 85 ans ou plus vos chances
d'être atteint d'alzheimer sont les
mêmes et pour ceux et celles qui seront
pas atteints vous devrez probablement
accompagner quelqu'un qui le sera au
cours de votre vie je dis pas ça pour
vous faire peur ou aimer la déprime
longmont était incertain mais c'est
parce que je veux que vous compreniez
pourquoi je pense qu'il va être utile
pour vous de savoir ce que la muse et
personnalisée peut accomplir pour une
personne atteinte d'alzheimer
nous utilisons tous la musique dans
notre vie pour accompagner nos émotions
ou nos activités on mène ce nous écrite
mais pour faire d'exercice on vient de
le voir une petite musique douce pour
accompagner notre père romantique et en
plus de ça la musique
elle a aussi le pouvoir de nous ramener
dans un événement passé c'est que notre
cerveau est programmé pour lier musique
et mémoire à l'automne 2014
j'ai été inspiré en regardant un
documentaire qui s'intitule un live et
inside ce documentaire présenté le
travail de dan kun le fondateur du
programme music in memory d'un coût net
un américain et un grand amateur de
musique rock
en 2006 une question qui préoccupait qui
se fait un jour je dois aller vivre
ensemble d'hébergement venge avoir accès
à la musique préférée il a fait une
enquête et s'est aperçu qu'aucune des 16
mai les résidences pour aînés des états
unis nos frais cette possibilité à
l'époque les petits baladeurs ipod est
extrêmement populaire alors dan saisis
soit ce serait le parfait petit appareil
pour me permettre d'écouter ma musique
sans que je les range mon entourage
alors il s'est proposé pas longtemps
il a instauré un programme offrant un
petit ipod à chacun des résidents d'une
résidence new yorkaise et dans lesquels
avaient téléchargé leur propre musique
je dois vous dire qu'ils ont une
statistique dans les résidences pour
personnes aînées
il ya une forte majorité de gens qui
sont atteints d'alzheimer alors dame au
plus constaté ce qu'apportait la musique
personnalisé à ces gens quand je parle
de musique personnalisé je parle de la
musique qui nous allume la musique qui
est significative pour nous son objectif
était simple un d'apporter du bonheur
mais à faire écouter la musique aux gens
elle s'est aperçue que il était capable
de faire refouler certains des pires
symptômes de la maladie d'alzheimer
c'est un peu comme si la musique en
entrant profondément dans les turcs coin
du cerveau ses recoins et là qui sont
pas atteints par l'alzheimer permettait
aux personnes de se réveiller de re
devenir qu'ils étaient et enfin d'avoir
accès à leurs souvenirs et vu que une
image vaut mille mots
j'aimerais que vous puissiez regarder
avec moi un petit extrait du
documentaire qui m'attend inspiré
à la spa
nous amuser
regarde
pourquoi croyez vous aux commerçants
et si in baby doc restent à prendre
mitri qui lines ap
et nous nous sommes les premiers bail au
musée de la musique et le bar neal black
music only one day
bien sûr que nous serons présents sous
ministre
on était amis tout on a su modeler
de lomé
tout animal aurait pris naissance dans
tout et vous comprenez qu'après avoir vu
ces images il devenait impératif pour
nous à la société alzheimer laval
d'apporter ce genre d'expérience aux
gens qu'on accompagne au quotidien
j'ai donc contacté john cohen et
quelques mois plus tard nous sommes
devenus la première source québécoise
est certifié music and memri en 2014 le
programme était plus ou moins connus au
québec
et moi j'en ai parlé à gauche et à
droite et c'est comme ça que je suis
devenu un petit peu comme la porte
parole francophone du programme même si
je n'ai jamais travaillé pour music and
memory
ce qui est fantastique avec ce genre de
doughty c'est qu' il n'y a aucune
contre-indication ya c'est facile
d'accès c'est à la portée tout le monde
ça coûte trop cher on n'a pas besoin
d'être un médecin ou un spécialiste pour
le mettre en application
suffit d'avoir un petit ipod casque
d'écouté et ont pu entrer en contact
avec quelqu'un sans passer par tous les
filtres de la maladie c'est vraiment
impressionnant de voir ce que l' écoute
de la musique personnalisé fait chez
quelqu'un qui est atteint d'alzheimer
mais l'été dernier j'ai été témoin de
quelque chose que je n'aurais jamais pu
imaginer il ya un très gentil monsieur
qu'on accompagne depuis plusieurs années
est chez lui la maladie d'alzheimer de
lourdes conséquences physiques marché
pour lui c'est très difficile alors ils
avancent toujours attrait
un petit port hésitant extrêmement
lentement et un après midi qu'il
écoutait sa musique préférée
dans son cas c'est la musique
sud-américaine gelé vu danser une samba
comme un vrai professionnel
il ya quelque chose d' extrêmement
émouvant avoir quelqu'un veut devenir
qui il était j'en ai encore des frissons
aujourd'hui je savais que la musique
pouvait apporter beaucoup de bonheur aux
personnes atteintes
on leur a apporté du calme quand on est
en période d'anxiété qu'on fait
communiquer avec eux plus facilement
quand il écouter leur musique mais que
la musique un tel effet sur les
capacités physiques de quelqu'un
j'aurais jamais pu l'imaginer
aujourd'hui dans le monde selon les
statistiques de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé il ya 47 points 5 millions
de personnes atteintes d'alzheimer ou
d'une maladie apparentée
si comme moi vous êtes inspirés par ce
que peut faire la musique personnalisés
quand vous en aurez l'occasion ramener
la vie à quelqu'un merci